hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dimension 2 now I'm
just playing it from before so I'm still
making my way through this place then I
don't know a lot about it but so far
from what I've seen this guy completely
insane like Jesus
those guys startled me more than like
the monsters oozes cuz they come out of
nowhere and at least before they weren't
totally silent huh listen I know yeah I
know I'm telling you and you're probably
just doing your job you just paid to do
this I feel really bad but I really
don't feel bad at all ok so can I go up
here I think the reason the combat is a
little bit funky is because this was
originally meant like I said before it
was a Nintendo DSi ok I'm not gonna do
that because if I did freeze you'd
probably just kill me anyway I'm gonna
stab you to death with a prison check
I'm really sorry about this and by sorry
I mean I'm really not sorry at all I
mean you're just a video game character
so I still feel bad Oh blood okay all
right there yeah as an original DF no la
bar you get back your wife and kids oh I
thought I'd killed him in like two hits
oh man I'm getting really good at this
murder thing I'm sure I didn't kill my
wife
am I like Harrison Ford I didn't kill my
my Harrison Ford sounds a lot like Santa
I didn't kill my I didn't kill my wife
didn't do it I didn't kill my wife
okay where am I now it's a part you were
just the beginning he's already started
phase two things are going to get much
worse
but I'm William I'm William Redmond read
more what her so is me
excuse me what what what hell
Oh God Jesus what the hell where'd you
come from you I'll use you Swezey little
bastards guy kippy scaring me like that
you're just tiny can't see in the
darkness Wow
I can't see in the dark Jesus how's the
most intense jump I've ever had in my
entire life this game is like 50%
comical and 50% Gary and then another
50% very weird actually really like I'm
actually it's not bad I mean maybe I'm
spoiled because oh hey BAM you're out
key notice out hates have to aim like
this on a DS well alright yeah if I
can't aim on a PC I sure as [ __ ] can't
aim on IBS I'm gonna just shank you to
that it takes longer but for maybe it
wouldn't because I just keep missing
maybe they should come out with me with
MS me with with me and on me with
something a bit more than a baton oh oh
oh oh one of those now those spiders
very low detail spiders haha at first I
was like oh and then I started knows oh
they're just things yes still don't like
him I never mentioned I don't really
like spiders all that much like I don't
have a strong phobia for them like uh
some people do but I a big fan of spider
Oh what the hell it's snowing it's
almost pretty like to be honest it
doesn't look bad at all
awfully nice and cozy I like the
wintertime oh hey hi okay you want to
play now okay that's weird it has like
the same music all the time and I think
I'm gonna get job alarma oh yeah and
then nothing I think all of my voices
for everything is oh this looks useful
what what looks useful what huh
Oh what the hell I didn't even see that
but I can smash some wood with this
probably you're bad who have a charger
bar you want some
somebody wants some I got my hammer
ready to go whoo what's up laughs oh god
what are you oh how are you Oh
die oh please die oh you are weird
yeah like a headcrab but happened with
more brain ah am I in the crazy world
there am I in the normal world I can't I
don't even know anymore
uh what's in here Oh huh hey hey there
pretty lady a guy I don't know what you
are all right so it's a note we all must
stay folks are gonna wonder why Doug an
escape tunnel and never used it the
thing is cursed I dug for three months
working night labor in the boiler room
locked in all night nobody but me check
that gage mop the floors dig cover the
hole every morning after ten feet I
broke through to a natural cave but
there are things in that cave I boarded
it up and never went back
I'd rather die in this cell then go back
to that tunnel Pierre Z all right don't
got my spit what I meant to say was
birthday okay
where the hell what does that mean what
kind of gibberish is all this did you
[ __ ] on the ceiling there's a toilet oh
yeah all right never mind then I'm gonna
go out the door get on the floor
everybody do they're done okay good I
like the ambiance definitely good [ __ ]
you
what is it what is it
this is a cloud of boxed can I hit it
with my hammer this is that you know
what to do what do I do
oh I'm just gonna run you know what
screw that I don't know how to deal with
that I don't know at all how do i oh I
went in a Lube oh I went in a
loop-de-loop and now I can go here
FIF what was that was that me I make
some very strange noises I will just
admit the sound design in this game is
actually cool what I didn't get to read
that okay never it's a note it's uh what
it's a it's a note kinda oh there we go
you'll never guess what I just heard one
of this head security guards talking
about it barely they're flying in a ton
of Russian inmates oh they're arriving
next Tuesday he say was saying that
they're dirt cheap and there's no paper
trail to worry about can you believe
that I don't know if this is true or
just a joke but I wouldn't put it past
them cheap bastards anyway I'll see you
in a couple weeks after I get back from
with gansan Menace not learning some
Russian my brother I don't know what
accent that was do not quote me on that
one examine him
oh no everybody um all right more ammo
all right let me just pull out my gun
who wants dumb am I gonna go into crazy
Banco world anytime soon is there gonna
be another smitty werben jaegerman
jensen coming after me
heed me what is that I say something
over there what is that what is that
what is it oh it's a stand in the wall
never mind sorry it was dark I couldn't
see what are you extract I didn't know
yeah yeah you're dumb
I need to save I haven't saved in a long
time I'm haben then to this day point
over here cuz my health is actually kind
of low but oh those kind of pills huh
okay so apparently I don't need to save
unless this game suddenly crashes
without hate out hate there was some
reports of this crashing when I was
doing some research I'm gonna go stave
I'm gonna go all the way make the long
haul back to the state point back this
way sorry I apologize you would you like
to hear a story while I'm wandering did
you guys know that I used to go to band
camp like back when I was in the seventh
grade I was actually in marching van I
did all sorts of stuff like that the
band camp was the weirdest thing like
ever in the entire world because it was
just oh what am i oh
go this way yeah band camp was very
weird because it was bunch of uh a kids
that had like just hit puberty so they
were like hormonal raging all locked in
cabins together very strange place to be
in a very strong strange time to be
there so um what was even weirder is
that like everyone was telling stories
about how you know 13 and 12 year old
kids were like oh yeah I Bank so many
girls when I was at band camp yeah or
when I was back home I'm yeah I'm
exactly ten million times and it was
just the strangest thing to like hear
these from people and I was just a
little kid like I never made any claims
to this that myself but I was just
listening like oh yeah yeah no
definitely I pull it we got the [ __ ]
man just both year old market barges
like mm-hmm
those are nerdiest kid too so like I was
not anything at all though I had no
experience I didn't even know I like
girls dead oh oh it's a dead guy ugly
got anyway yeah so uh band camp was also
weird because then they had this dance
like they had this strange dance for
kids there that they wanted to pair
people off it was blue legs fine arts
camp admission
by the way I don't know if any of you
out there I've ever attended but um they
they had this weird dance at the end and
they made like people pair up like they
picked people randomly the camp
counselors would run around be like you
and you you and you you're together now
go dance have fun yeah and then like the
kids would just be like ah Hurley hey
hmm no you're pretty I got paired up
with someone and I'm not saying I was
like super attraction star like I wasn't
a catch by any means but I had some
going for me and then like afterwards
after the counselor paired me up she
turned me down she was like came out
after measly yeah I don't wanna like I
still like dance with you but I don't
want to go with you and I'm like oh oh
that's okay uh that was fine I mean it's
alright like I'd understand I wouldn't
want to go with me to sleep totally cool
like whatever you want to do what I
should have said was [ __ ] you
I'm markiplier now yeah look at me I'm
playing video games and telling my
embarrassing tough good god don't do
that okay you're Pocky Oh nailed you to
the ground uh yeah well okay you could
die that'd be nice okay dad now good hey
wait yeah so yeah look at me now
whatever your name was I don't even
remember
that's how unimportant you are to me so
yeah okay haha that's what I made this
channel for just to get redemption on
all on all my past transgressions that's
all there's a standpoint right here ah
ah damn it what a waste of my life hey
where does this go oh okay
no absolute I like cheese okay okay I
don't care I don't like you that much I
mean not like make-or-break for me
oh cool what the Oh what did I just do
with that flashlight I think I shoulda
sugared it
that's cheeky stickers you guys let's
check it oh oh oh what are you oh oh
good yeah damn I'm a ledge ham you wait
how do I wait a minute there we go
how about Elvis oh you're dead good I
just think I had a hurt am i oh
add a brewski ass right oh come here
come on you want some Wow let me hammer
into you for a little bit let me this
this is a very drastic issue I don't
mean to hammer the point
I know these puns aren't working I don't
have any hammer puns I got a sponge okay
I don't know what the hell that shadow
thing was Oh thing to do with that one I
can handle the monsters but that shadow
thing back on what the [ __ ]
God Jesus Oh go die in a fire you
[ __ ] how do I kill you I don't think
I can
what do I do it when it goes red hey
maybe what am i doing anything
come on that's fair we do huh ha ha ha
and I like you okay I think I have to go
this way alright that's fun
yeah Dave huh alright then
well
take another tripping nightmare land I
guess cuz I don't have any other choice
I'm not gonna waste my ammo trying to
keep that thing if it's not doing
anything are you where are you buddy
where'd you go where'd you run off to
where'd you run up oh oh okay I'm not
gonna shoot at him if I come across them
I'm just gonna oh you okay okay okay
yeah no not that way how did I get
flipped around like that ass you guys
you guys you guys should get out of here
get out of here I'm just quoting the
game grumps all day today oh good I can
run it I don't think I am supposed to
kill him
probably just a red herring to be able
to kill him but oh sugar so guys that's
Jake you see it ah
come on get out here oh come on did I
oh oh oh thanks give me the heebie
jeebies okay I can make it around okay
okay there we go there we go there we go
ah ooh they're creepy I hate things that
you can't kill like things that you
can't kill her very disturbing like dead
space the original one I really liked it
well I really liked you read the book
good yeah
I really like the original dead space
and maybe I shouldn't be talking about
past things when I have very pressing
matters in this one but I really I
really liked oh god look away from me
away from me yeah I love how it's just
so much effort to jump oh yeah he's just
jumping like breaking both my legs
maybe my legs are broken anyway I like
that space one because of the
regenerator was just the first time I
played it you so scared oh god I'm not
gonna make this ah
damn you straight to hell if I'm not
there already okay these enemies are not
much of a threat I gotta admit now that
I got the sledgehammer nope I marry you
nope up no what did you like your head
not caved in oh I'm so sorry
yeah deep breath turkey get out okay
another one down hey yeah I got to make
sure when I get out of the crazy world
that I go the right way the correct way
okay which is aa
bargain what oh god damn but what am I
supposed to do and piss piss piss balls
I'm not gonna make it I'm not gonna make
it I got to go back hopefully respawns
location okay please tell me ah what are
we gonna do Oh what do I do
I have to go in again Oh wanna uh oh hi
okay I'm just gonna I'm gonna blow your
brains up
I don't have time to waste I'm in a bit
of a hurry
oh come on they take three shots that's
baloney trying to get head shots but I
mean this is his balloony load of
baloney well I gotta go ting huh King
y'all right there
I'm coming after you I'm gonna be there
soon but you're in dirt okay
all right thank you for that uh oh this
one doesn't stop this was so rude in no
Oh
stop over your head just for that I'm
gonna sledgehammer the sledgehammer Shou
you give us key full power school and
there we go now please don't spawn me
right on top of it Wow
oh I see oh okay oh so it spawns you in
the same location after you get zip
zapped into the next dimension okay I
got it I got it here oh I see I didn't
realize I was in this part okay okay
okay hey hey Oh down here I went the
wrong way
Oh God your God stop doing that to me
you're very disturbing Oh even though
you yourself are not physically
threatening to me ah I love house just
so much work okay
oh come on give me a save point where me
what about you oh the boiler room is
where that guy made his thing
Chicka Chicka sure what the hell is that
that looks like a dagger well I got a
ship okay nope that ain't the thing okay
do I need to I'm gonna just reuse my I'm
not gonna waste my bullets I don't want
to waste
just in case they are precious than I do
need them for something cuz I imagine
that the enemies are gonna get tougher
very soon
okay not cool man you have fun with that
you have a good damn hey ice trick is
you okay anyway I'm actually all out
time for this part uh hopefully I hit a
save point pretty soon I imagine they're
gonna pace it pretty regularly but
anyway I really like in this game I
really am I was surprised when I went to
I was like it could be good this is
actually isn't bad
I really am enjoying it especially
considering it's a DES port holies did
okay anyway so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos I've done as always I will see
you in the next video
ah
No
chasing you losing or something
six of a family four
I know